all right norma and chrissy
norma and chrissy uh norma where did you
grow up where are you from originally uh
the south bay
and uh tell me about your family growing
up you had mom and dad
yeah my parents were they were um
you know they were good parents um
they were in their 30s and they had me
um
and
um
i you know i have a lot of good memories
um
i miss them a lot you know i wish i saw
them more but
um
you know life kind of takes you
unexpected places there's a good
childhood basically yeah not a good
childhood yeah
and chrissy tell me about where you grew
up
um
i grew up
in long beach
both parents in the home but my dad was
extremely abusive
to my mom
so my siblings and i witnessed that
growing up
it was really hard
my dad was an alcoholic
and
yeah so by the time my mom left him
we were i was six i think and
she basically had to hide us because he
threatened to kidnap all of us
um and
yeah but my mom
was a single mom after that and she did
her best to give us everything
we didn't want for anything
she put herself through school and you
know started her own business
and she was a really good role model for
me
you guys both made it through high
school yeah
anything after high school college or
anything
some college some college
and
so today you're living on skid row
yeah we live downtown l.a
how did this happen
um
it's interesting
um
i don't know it's
it's crazy the things that you get used
to not having
you know like you know lights and
heater and stuff like that um but you
know when we have money for hotel rooms
we get hotel rooms
um like you know the storm coming
tomorrow we'll definitely be staying in
a hotel for that um
[Music]
but you're in a tent otherwise
yeah
yeah it's a hard lifestyle
is it not yeah
it is
how long you've been down here
like
a year a year
a year
yeah
yeah it's nice we have like our own like
our little own little community down
here though you know like we watch out
for each other
so you know
her and i walk around down here at night
without fear you know
it's people think it's like this big
scary place and you know all these
horrible people down here but they're
really not
you know they've helped us a lot they've
done a lot for us you know
they're really amazing people down here
you have a very different story to tell
than some people
yeah i mean yeah no there's some pretty
like
beautiful like really amazing people
down here i've like found more more of
that than not you know yeah definitely
i mean there's always
a couple bad apples you know and like
there's other parts of the city like
macarthur park that um
we consider a little more
treacherous
yeah shady
so we kind of try to stay away from
there
and what is your drug
what drugs are you guys using
fentanyl both of you fentanyl um
crack here and there
a little bit of
meth how do you support yourself
um
hustling
um boosting
prostitution kind of whatever we need to
to make ends meet
do you do you find this lifestyle
difficult
it can be
you've had a pretty rosy picture of it a
second ago
yeah
it's more i feel like monotonous i feel
like it's the same thing over and over
yeah
um
and that's like exhausting you know
but
it's not you know
we have hope that it's not going to be
like this forever
getting clean from fentanyl is going to
be a challenge though
yeah
yeah
yeah but i mean we have each other and i
think that helps we and we've done it
before yeah we've done it before
we kicked it cold turkey twice
so
it's just
our and
we always end up
kind of
gravitating back towards the old
lifestyle old people places
um so i know that you know when we do
really want to get clean we have to
cut the cord which probably means
leaving l.a
do you have your friends other than each
other
yeah yeah
yeah a couple
you really have to be careful who you
trust you think you can trust people and
then
they turn around and steal from you or
you know
just stab you in the back somehow
because everyone out here is looking to
come up
and um
we're an easy target we're two females
you know
um
but we have each other's backs
what do you guys worry about
what are you afraid of
being down here forever
you have been stuck here yeah stuck it's
easy to get stuck there's a good chance
of that
yeah there's a lot of people that have
been down here for decades
yeah
yeah
i'm afraid of like the people certain
people around here you know i've been
like robbed i've been like beaten up you
know that's why her face looks like that
yeah she just got robbed and beaten up
the other day in macarthur park
i know it was in macarthur park but
one of the people was from there um
[Music]
it was at the train station oh what the
[ __ ] yeah
um
so you know there is like that scary
aspect to it but
and it's like
i'm just like
in awe like how
that can like happen and how
it can like happen again and again you
know and people just stand by and watch
yeah they don't help they don't give a
[ __ ]
they really don't care they can see a
female being beaten up
robbed raped and they'd look the other
way
even the police they don't even the cops
yeah they don't give a [ __ ]
do you guys get depressed or anxious or
angry like that yeah of course well i
just got to take a toll on you
emotionally right yeah yeah
yeah it definitely wears on our souls i
think
it's very frustrating yeah very
frustrating you had each other though
that must help right
yeah i don't i don't know what i would
do without her i don't i would
i would be lost
how'd you guys first get introduced to
drugs
hard drugs
my siblings my older siblings older
friends that i had when i was a teenager
um my dad used to use like drugs and
alcohol and
um one of his friends
i got it through one of his friends
or started using hard drugs
you guys still
in contact with your families
yes yeah
yeah they must be concerned for you no
um
yeah um
they're not happy with
our lifestyle but
you know they
they love us
my mom's amazing like she buys us
christmas pajamas
yeah yeah
yeah i don't really tell details to my
family you know i don't want to like
worry them or yeah feel judged or
anything you know yeah
what does your typical day look like you
guys wake up
get well
so you have some stored up from the
night before always always you always
have to have the wake up
get well um
kind of like assess our financial
situation see how much money we need to
make for the day
um what our drug supply looks like and
when we need to pick up and then it's
just this kind of
constant cycle of like
you know boosting or you know
doing what we need to do to get money to
get well you know finding the connect
how you know how much do we have left
okay you can't can't get sick can't get
sick
you know then go to the connect pickup
okay we're good and then you know do it
all over again because if you don't get
your fix you're we are extremely sick
extremely sick it's not pretty
but we're pretty good about rationing
and um
you know
not um going overboard
like planning it just is constant
planning
what's your biggest regret
um
not being able to give her like the life
that like
i think she deserves not being able to
protect her like when these things
happen
um probably moving the highway oh god
yeah that too yeah
that's where it all started yeah
do you find being down here is easier
than hollywood
it's different there's more community
here
yeah
hollywood's very doggy dog
yeah it's different different vibe
yeah less camaraderie yeah
hollywood's kind of every man for
himself and you know like
tear each other down to get to the top
what you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
don't
judge people
you know don't you know people can look
at us and assume things judge us um but
you never know what people are going
through you know you see you know a bum
begging for change on the sidewalk and
like to some people like
they just think oh like you know
look at the piece of trash but it's like
society's failed him
he could have mental health issues
substance abuse issues you know on top
of like being incarcerated where they
don't get any help for any of that and
then they just throw them back on the
streets and they're they're like
somebody's brother somebody's that's
someone's family that's someone's family
member
sister whoever yeah
um and people like forget that you know
they like dehumanize them which is yeah
and i bet it would be different if it
was one of their family members
going through it you know
addiction can touch anybody this could
happen to anybody it's very easy to come
down here and get stuck
very easy
all right norma and chrissy thank you so
much for sharing your stories thank you
i wish you guys the best of luck
thank you thanks
you